it is very autobiographical not in terms
of necessarily every moment in the film
but the characters upon which the story
is based these were it was based upon
family members and I I tried to
delineate those complex things that I
saw within my family that made made this
a compelling story for me and hopefully
for you well I was very friendly with
Andie McDowell's agent and he and I
would spend long hours trying to figure
out who to cast in the film and he at
one point said to me I think you should
really consider Andie I know she's not
necessarily someone you would think of
in this role but I think I think she
might be able to do the part and I think
she would enjoy it and I think it would
be something that she'd find challenging
and I met with her and I found in her
fragility that I thought was the essence
of this character and she really wanted
to do the part and she came on board
very excited about it and she knew it
was gonna be a stretch to do the accent
she worked with three different dialect
coaches I finally had her her final
version looked at by Tim Manik who is a
very well-known
dialect coach and he he gave her the
green light and said that she was she
was doing really well I think but has
been hard for some audiences is just
knowing how Andy typically speaks and
then seeing her for the first few
moments can be somewhat jarring but
after Andy came on board
Chaz palm and Terry I got the script to
him I he was really one of my first
choices for the role of of Joe and I
think not and obviously not because he's
Jewish he's not but I thought he could
relate to the character and I thought
that he could play this character and I
thought he was probably one of the few
people out there who could do do justice
to this role because he has such an
ominous quality to him but also such a
lovable quality and I sent it to him and
somehow got it through the
wall of agents that often keeps keeps
low-budget filmmakers from reaching
their cast destinations and he he took a
look at the script and I got a phone
call from him almost immediately that he
wanted to play the role and from there
on in he was so committed and so excited
about the project and I think working
with him has been possibly the greatest
experience of my entire professional
career he is just such first of all in
my opinion a brilliant actor but also I
I would say the quintessential mensch
Chaz sent me an email and it was so nice
I actually hung it up and he said and he
said don't worry about what the critics
say don't worry about what the box
office is we've screened this for enough
people to know that this touches people
and you've made something good here and
I know it will have a life and I thought
that was just so beautiful and so
supportive and I love him for that and
the one thing he asked me along the way
was after helping me in the way that he
did he said to me I just have one
request for you and that is that you
help someone else in the future and
again I thought you know that just shows
the nature of this man and his his
completely generous spirit